what's up guys it's marcus brownlee here
from mkbhd and welcome to another video
and this video is actually going to be
not a rant not not maybe it is a rant i
don't know but i'm just going to be
putting something out there putting an
update sort of out there and just
letting you guys know a few things that
you probably need to know
so as of late getting more and more
subscribers and friends and you know
people that i know on youtube lately i'm
getting a lot of people asking me about
um videos that i've already done now
this is no offense to anyone's already
asked me that
um
so say someone was looking for a video
on safari safari 4 and they you know
they typed in safari 4 in the top search
box on youtube safari 4. and you hit
enter or hit search and you'll get all
the videos from everyone
and anyone who's ever uploaded video on
safari 4 so you see there's a number of
them one of them happens to be mine
but say you want a faster way
to upload or to find one of my videos
because i've had a lot of people say
well i want to know your video about
safari but i don't feel like searching
through all 216 of your videos to find
it
well here is a better way if you didn't
already notice there is a search box
under the my video section of youtube
where you can search all my videos for
keywords so here we go i'll search
safari for
and you hit the enter button or the
search button and you'll see all my
videos that have to do with safari for
whether i've
included it in the title or the
description or the tags of the video so
the one you might be looking for is hd
tutorial safari 4.0 so you go ahead and
click on that so yeah uh i've decided
that from now on if someone ever asks me
you know oh where did you get those
backgrounds yes that probably sounds
familiar to you guys i'll just point you
down here to the search box
and i'm just going to answer your
questions saying i actually already did
a video about my wallpapers and i'll cl
i'll include the keyword in your answer
in all capital letters so like if you
post a comment on this video not that
you need to or message me or something
through youtube and say
can you do a video about your or about
skype i'll actually say i already
actually did a video about skype and
then i'll you know make skype in all
capital letters so you'll go down to the
video search box on youtube and say
s-k-y-p-e skype and bam there's all the
videos i've done
about skype a microphone for skype a
skype review a tutorial on upgrading to
skype or maybe say you go back to my
channel and you say wow nice wallpaper i
know someone's gonna ask that where did
you get your wallpaper i'll say i
actually did a video on where i get all
my wallpapers and someone will say oh
that's all in caps
wallpapers enter
and there's all the videos i've ever
done including hd tutorial quality
wallpapers requests so many people have
asked me that
so there you go guys i'm probably going
to start including a link from now on in
all my videos as to where as to the
exact wallpaper i got
i'm just going to show you guys real
quick most of the wallpapers i've been
getting recently are from a specific
website so if i exit out of safari here
and i go up in mozilla firefox i
actually did a tutorial on how to
instantly get backgrounds using mozilla
firefox
so if i open up mozilla firefox here
which is using a google chrome theme
most of the backgrounds i've gotten so
far are from
wall.alphacoders.com which i included in
my wallpaper video and you can also find
actually a lot of them i've been getting
have been over in this search box the
navigation search and i just type in cgi
hit enter
and hit the first link which is while
that alphacoders.com all the cgi
wallpapers and here you'll see
pretty much like eight or nine of my
latest wallpapers are from this page
right here the first few pages you
probably remember that black and red one
right there yeah you've asked
you probably remember if i go to this
next page here you'll probably recognize
a few of them that i've used in my
previous videos so i'm going to try to
include a link to my wallpaper that i'm
using in the video uh from now on just
so you guys don't have to ask anymore
uh so that's basically it thanks for
watching this one yes this wallpaper
link i'll try to throw up in the
description for you guys and uh just in
case you ever asked for a video i've
already done make sure to check my
youtube channel uh check that exact
search box before you ask me and if you
do ask i'll obviously include that
keyword in all capital letters so thanks
for watching this update mkbhd going
back and forth between hardware and
software here hope you enjoy thanks for
watching guys peace